my name is Anna Crispo I've been working
here at the council for the last five
years I started doing a traineeship I
had the pleasure to be at the trust
office precisely with the deputy
spokesperson of the Herman Van Rompuy
the former president of the European
councils and well since then I've been
having different positions and always
connected to Communication and Media and
right now I am the assistant to the
director as well for media and
communications I really wanted to be at
the press office and and not only
because the sector is communications and
that's what I want to my professional
career to be in but also because I knew
that this was a highly competent and
very important place to be in the
traineeship program I was told at up at
the moment that it was great and why
because we are very few in here you are
part of a team you get to you get to go
with a supervisor to negotiations follow
hand-in-hand what is going on and this
is invaluable from the council you can
get this kind of experience that will
remain with you your entire life here
you can grasp negotiating skills
leadership skills just by seeing who is
around you you can develop your writing
skills oral speaking like Bob wood
speaking so there are a lot of this soft
skills that certainly it will be very
valuable for your career and I think
certainly you will have them
entertaining